Kansas se prepara para tomarle el pulso
al aborto Este martes este estado
estadounidense de cerca de tres millones
de habitantes vota para decidir si sigue
protegiendo el derecho al aborto en su
Constitución Estatal o si por el
contrario se permite a los legisladores
regular sobre esta cuestión sin
injerencia de la justicia hasta el
momento la participación temprana indica
Un aumento de la movilización Respecto a
los comicios estatales de 2018
creo que la votación temprana hasta esta
mañana era de cerca de 2.000 personas
más que en el 2018 También tenemos unas
mil personas más que solicitaron su
boleta electoral que hace cuatro años
Así que definitivamente tenemos un
repunte en el registro de votantes y de
gente que sale ejercer su derecho
en la actualidad Kansas permite
interrumpir los embarazos hasta la
semana 20 de gestación pero obliga a que
las mujeres se sometan a un
asesoramiento y un periodo de espera de
24 horas antes de practicárselo para
algunos esto debe cambiar ya
el aborto es quitar una vida si la gente
quiere ser promiscua y acá va quedando
embarazada es el resultado del pecado
que ya cometió no necesitan cometer un
segundo pecado
el voto es el primero en Estados Unidos
después de la derogación de la sentencia
de Rober versus wade que protegía este
derecho a escala Federal los activistas
a favor del aborto en Kansas han llegado
francamente un poco tarde a organizarse
creo que mucha gente quizás dio por
sentado el derecho al aborto aunque han
ganado algo de terreno Será interesante
ver lo que ocurre no creo que nadie
tenga una idea sólida de Cuál será el
resultado y lo que ocurre en Kansas será
sin duda un termómetro de la situación
del país respecto al aborto a escasos
cuatro meses de las elecciones de mitad
de mandato